okay here we go it's time for drew's
news your daily rip of the good news
poor strip
and with me at the desk is a man with
pores invisible to the naked
eye
everybody it's beauty week
rossi i am so excited about today's show
we got a big one today oh my gosh first
of all i love kicking beauty week off
yeah i love beauty week because we're
definitely about how it feels much more
than how it looks how it functions and
then boy do we have
okay i'm like so nervous i'm walking the
hallways i'm on michelle pfeiffer watch
she is here today
where is she
where is she
well she
is here i know i got a whole nervous
tummy going on just thinking i might
bump into her accidentally so
okay security all right well we're gonna
talk beauty week all week long and this
year
we're going big real big okay we're not
giving you one not five not ten
but 100 beauty tips all week long wow
that's right
that's right
so get out your pen get out your paper
it all starts right now i'm going to
start with my tip number one what is it
i prefer to pluck my eyebrows at night
because um
when you put makeup on freshly plucked
brows you are basically putting
uh pollutants right in the open pore oh
interesting so what i like to do is
pluck at night go to sleep wake up the
pores have tightened they have closed
and you're ready to face the day and put
your makeup on i love it at night i
never would have
i was
i don't do that good to know thanks for
the tip well here's my tip uh you know
they have those really expensive like
face washes so soaps uh well don't spend
your money on that i clean with just
this bottle i get at the drugstore for
nine dollars and it lasts me like two
weeks don't spend your money on cleaning
your face just use soap and then spend
your money on like the serums and the
lotions that's my tip
all right but first let's hit a few
headlines we're gonna start with beauty
get out those tweezers and start a
plucking maybe at night because this
skinny brow is back
that's right glamour magazine reports
that bushy brows had their moment but
it's over
and the brow pendulums are gonna swing
the other way back to the skinny
olivia wilde bella hadid and charlie's
thereon
they're all working a slim eyebrow um i
have loved a skinny brow myself yes
at one point i had basically one row um
i'm lucky that they grew back yeah
now i have you know bushy ones again
yeah i see i'm i don't know if i can say
this but i'm a fan of a
photo yeah i like
you know what i mean though like
if it looks like your eyebrows were done
with the ballpoint pen
maybe rethink them you know i think if
you have full of brows you should lean
into it if you have thin brows lean into
that okay yeah fair yeah i'm i yeah all
right well from brows to blonics that's
manolo blahniks thanks very much if
you're looking for a place to hang up
your heels right here in new york city
look no further than carrie bradshaw's
upper east side apartment remember where
carrie lives i love it that
studio apartment well l reports airbnb
teamed up with hbo max to recreate
carrie's rent-controlled one-bedroom and
you yes you you can stay for a night and
it's got all those carry touches like
the apple laptop that you would write
you know i couldn't help but wonder uh
her shoe collection and the crown jewel
and carry it in the apartment the closet
the walk-in closet the carry closet yes
well if you want to stay inside
department it's only 23 a night really
yeah which is like not even one tenth of
one manolo okay
but they're they've given that price to
celebrate 23 years since the start of
sex in the city
and bookings open up on monday at noon
so hey siri set an alarm
my question to you is if you were going
to stay in kerry's apartment would you
want to stay with big
aiden
or the russian
[Applause]
okay
i was asking drew thank you very much
so i guess a bunch of big fans yeah but
what do you think
um
i mean
alexander petrovsky is not a good guy
but he's played by mikhail barishnikov
so i've got marish the cop
because i love barista
[Music]